à la rigauderie vous êtes secrétaire
exécutive à l'IPBES expliquez-nous
qu'est-ce qui est en jeu dans ce nouveau
cadre mondial pour la biodiversité donc
véritablement maintenant la communauté a
une nouvelle chance de faire mieux et
cette fois-ci d'arriver à un point
tournant qui serait pour la première
fois un cadre qui se réchiffrer et
ambitieux en fait le cadre mondial
précédent celui d'Haïti de la vie de
tous a été une déception qu'est-ce que
vous en retenez on peut vraiment dire
que on a échoué à s'attaquer aux causes
directes de la perte de biodiversité
cependant il faut aussi souligner que
sans cette convention la situation
aurait été bien pire on peut par exemple
citer
l'augmentation du pourcentage d'air
protégé à la fois en zone marine ou en
zone terrestre et puis on estime que les
risques d'extinction auraient été deux à
quatre fois plus élevé pour ce qui est
des oiseaux et puis des mammifères sans
cette convention et que de la science
pour faire face à la crise actuelle de
la biodiversité la science elle dit que
il faut mettre en oeuvre le plan qu'on a
en tout cas celui de départ c'est-à-dire
les 30 % d'ici 2030 de zones protégées
marine et terrestre ça ça serait
vraiment fantastique ensuite on parle de
de restaurer 20% des écosystèmes
dégradés et puis après on parle de
modifier le les modèles agricoles de
diminuer l'utilisation des pesticides
des deux tiers et puis des engrais de la
moitié et il y a aussi la réduction de
certaines subventions on parle de
diminuer de 500 milliards de par an les
subventions néfastes à la biodiversité
et est-ce que les chiffres qui sont
présentés dans ce cadre sont à la
hauteur de ce qui demandait par la
science alors le projet de départ est à
la hauteur après il y a eu beaucoup de
discussions
avec beaucoup de propositions qui sont
contradictoires dont certaines
ignorent complètement les objectifs de
départ parce qu'en ce moment on est
c'est vraiment l'enjeu c'est beaucoup de
pays essaient de faire disparaître les
chiffres en fait et de garder que des
cibles qui seraient donc formulés de
manière de manière flouée ça ça serait
vraiment un échec oui on le voit presque
tous les chiffres sont encore débattus
en ce moment il reste beaucoup à faire
ce qui est en jeu c'est en fait le
destin de toutes les autres espèces avec
lesquelles l'être humain partage la
planète en fait ce sont vraiment des
questions de valeurs des questions
éthiques est-ce que on veut vraiment
vivre seul sur cette planète au-delà des
chiffres c'est vraiment la qualité de
notre vie qui qui vraiment est en jeu à
ce moment précis de notre histoire merci
Anne la rigauderie